[Music]
my name is clinton jones and i love
creating atmospheric photoreal 3d
renders
this full cg environment took me six
weeks to complete and stretched my
ability as a 3d artist so i'd love to
share some new things that i learned
along the way as well as some old tricks
i usually incorporate to elevate my 3d
art regardless of your skill level or
program of choice i believe this
breakdown will have something for
everybody so let's begin with sparking
the idea
growing up i've always had a fascination
for abandoned buildings i find a
mysterious tranquility in exploring
these forgotten places
there's an endless supply of texture to
photograph and the way in which nature
takes over these man-made structures is
a beautiful sight to see
the on-edge feeling i have while
exploring these unpredictable places
piques my creativity in a unique way
as a 3d artist i've always wanted to
create one of these environments myself
but knew it would come with endless
challenges the amount of detail required
to genuinely portray this kind of
environment would strike fear in even
the most seasoned artists
this is going to take patience
perseverance and drive
so to guide my journey ahead i need to
get inspired and gather reference
[Music]
over the years i've collected various
art books featuring unique locations
from around the world
massive sewers from japan long forgotten
cities from china and vast stepwells in
india i use my art books as idea
starters and for this project in
particular one book stood out
just 10 miles off the coast of nagasaki
is a forgotten coal mining island
hashima or battleship island once home
to 5 000 miners and their families was
abandoned in 1974 and since then nature
has taken its toll the images in this
book have given me a closer idea of the
environment i want to aim for
in the supplement i've pulled
screenshots from my favorite movies for
style tone and color reference and
compiled them in a program called puref
at this point i'm ready to create a bit
of concept art utilizing the reference
imagery i've gathered
the process of creating concept art is
my time to test out ideas and
efficiently put the image i see in my
head onto a screen a single piece of
concept art will act as a guide toward
my version 1 render but only through
experimentation will i discover my final
piece keep an open mind as you create
and don't blind yourself with a single
idea
and with that it's time to build the
foreground which will require the most
detail
and real displacement textures will give
me the highest quality results to get
the most out of these textures i'm
stacking three planes each with their
own texture
one muddy ground one slick wet ground
and another broken brick texture and
i'll control which texture is visible
using a displacement modifier powered by
a cinema 4d noise texture this grants me
full control over how much of each
individual texture is visible i'll add a
large area light in the distance
pointing toward the camera in order to
get a bit more detail off the
reflections in the mud then block out
some buildings to get a better feel of
the scene to add a bit more detail to my
foreground i'm using the quixote mega
scans library to scatter appropriate
items like rusted pipes old bottles cans
and mining equipment across the ground
i'll also add a few rubble piles and a
rusted barrel to add more texture to the
scene as well as some areas of raised
mud in the corners to keep things a bit
more realistic but before i go any
further i have to warn you guys about
virtual ram management luckily i'm
running an nvidia rtx quadro 6000 but
even with 24 gigabytes of virtual ram
this scene managed to use most of it
first use low res textures first
and only replace them at the end of your
project if you can clearly tell they're
low res this way you don't have to
replace every single texture when your
system inevitably locks up
second is to ensure your black and white
textures are red as such as opposed to
color textures which take up more vram
and finally use instances when
duplicating geometry instances reference
a model versus duplicating 30 versions
of the same mesh it's the only reason
i'm able to populate my scene with these
extremely high-res photo scans and only
by sticking to these three ram saving
tips was i able to complete this
ambitious scene
and finally to wrap out the foreground i
added a large storm drain that trails
off into the background but ran into an
issue when i realized there weren't any
storm drain textures online yeah there's
concrete textures but naturally storm
drains are made from endless slabs of
concrete that over time have collected
layer upon layer of unique texture
the two endless strips of concrete i saw
it were hidden underneath a massive
bridge
and inside an actual storm drain
for both i captured a series of images
with my iphone making sure to include
about 40 overlap between each shot in
lightroom i made batch edits to correct
for distortion perspective and aspect
ratio and stitched them together in
photoshop once my massive color map was
created i generated a normal map which
adds surface detail and a roughness and
specular map to decide how shiny our
concrete is and pretty soon here i'll be
releasing a start to finish in depth
video on how you can venture out take
some high quality textures and process
everything yourself so be sure to
subscribe to stay in the know this video
is brought to you by monk manual it's a
90-day planner designed to bring the
timeless wisdom of monk livin to your
everyday life i'm a true believer in the
idea that consistency and reflection is
the only way to truly master something
and the monk manual is specifically
designed to guide you through that
process
most planners only have space for your
schedule but the monk manual goes so
much further its daily pages are the
meat of the planner and help you
schedule your most important tasks track
habits you're working on and most
importantly reflect on your day's
progress and the weekly and monthly
pages allow you to zoom out and track
your progress over a longer period of
time in order to truly see how you're
doing so if you're trying to take on a
new challenge learn a new skill or
simply want to fill your life with a bit
more happiness the monk manual is for
you i've been using it for a while now
and couldn't recommend it more click the
link below use the code punisher that's
p-w-n-i-s-h-e-r
to get 10 off any order and start
tracking your growth today
so now that we've made a custom storm
drain let me show you guys how i created
my custom character
i wanted something a bit more unique
than your average miximo character for
the surrender so i pieced together a
costume half motorcycle gear half rock
climbing equipment and take a bunch of
photos from every angle in an area with
no directional light one pass at chest
level one pass above the head and
another super low will do the trick in
this case
i processed my images in a program
called reality capture which generates a
detailed 3d mesh from the series of
images since the photo scan comes at
such a high poly count i derez the mesh
in c4d export in fbx and auto rig it
with miximo adobe's free motion capture
library from here i'll re-export as a
t-pose back into c4d and now i have my
custom character rigged and ready for
animation and to keep things custom i'll
control my character with a rococo
motion capture suit i looped the walk
cycle in rococo studio check out this
video right here if you guys want to
learn how i added my character to this
custom mocap data
at this point our render is looking nice
but i'm just not happy with it i need to
add a story to this piece and only by
adding story will this overplayed genre
have any chance of becoming unique so
let's clearly define our character by
adding a few character specific items
like carabiners a bundle of rope and
some more rock climbing equipment next
i'll add an old robot into our storm
drain i'll add a machine gun nest to
insinuate a war between man and machine
now not that original but hey it's
better than nothing and some 50 cow
shells scattered across the mud for some
added detail
and already this is better than no story
where does it take you guys
leave a comment down below
before we hop into after effects to add
animated atmosphere in a cinematic color
grade we need to fine-tune what i think
is the most important step
i'm talking about lighting only by
fine-tuning your lights in the absence
of light can we achieve stunning results
currently our scene is lit by a single
grey image and a simple area light to
catch detail in our ground reflections
the only other light i'll add is the sun
but now there's a problem because we've
lost our dark dramatic mood we've cast
light over the entire landscape so i'll
need to block light with specifically
placed non-reflective black planes
called flags this is exactly what would
happen on a real world movie set my goal
is to only illuminate the story elements
creating a more dramatic scene so let's
begin by placing a flag above the camera
in order to cast a shadow across our
foreground this naturally vignettes the
landscape i'll add another flag to the
area behind our subject naturally
spotlighting our character and i'll
place one last flag to highlight the old
robot and machine gun nest believe it or
not this process took me about a day or
two to get right so don't be discouraged
if the fine tuning takes longer than you
think i promise it'll be worth it
and before we render an image sequence
i'll make sure to cue up a z depth pass
which is crucial for adding animated
smoke in after effects but let's start
with a cinematic color grade i always
begin with my shadows mid-tones and
highlights also known as lift gamma and
gain locking these light values in first
ensures that you can see the detail in
the darkest shadows and the brightest
highlights before tweaking color once
things look nice i'll push my shadows to
blue and bring out the green for a nice
complementary color boost i'll also
bring a bit more warmth into the
highlights and give the entire image a
saturation boost finally let's add a
subtle vignette and now we have a nice
cinematic color grade
currently our character is blending in
with the background so we need to find a
creative way to add contrast there's a
site called action vfx that not only has
the largest selection of stock footage
elements but their stock footage is the
highest quality as well i'll use their
atmospheric smoke and fog pack to bring
my render to life and draw attention to
specific elements by increasing contrast
in specific areas
this will take our render to the next
level
and finally after adding some subtle
film grain to dirty up our render and a
sound design pass to round things out
our art is complete
just remember if you guys can picture it
you can create it
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you